pleasure why why is your zipper or your
buttons down on your crotch
well I probably just forgot an accused
rapist is caught with his pants unzipped
in a truck full of underage kids during
a traffic stop in New Mexico
okay and then you have a bunch of kids
in the car how many kids you have one
two three four five six pour these kids
to you
this is my friend that's your friend the
disturbing traffic stop happened on July
5th of last year in Albuquerque New
Mexico dash camera footage shows a
driver later identified as 41 year old
Jeremy Guthrie speeding across multiple
Lanes of Highway before taking a
dangerous turn
okay after this near crash Guthrie is
pulled over by New Mexico State Patrol
Sergeants
foreign
how are you all right just all right
yeah okay shoot your license
body camera video shows a sergeant
comment on Guthrie's erratic driving
there's a wall right there between your
legs
sorry it was a little bit nervous
so was I the way you're driving
huh that's it
you mentioned that you were nervous
right I was George while I was behind
you driving down I-40 you in Lane number
one at times you only from Lane number
one all the way over then your signal
had problems keeping your your your your
beagle one lane and then when you merge
on from westbound 40 to Northbound 25
you take that curve way too fast
I did I'm sorry I thought you're gonna
crash
no I don't know I didn't say I don't
think so I'm just saying I thought you
were gonna crash
the first responder then comments on the
six children inside the vehicle
officials later confirmed the kids were
between 13 and 14 years old okay and
then you have a bunch of kids in the car
how many kids you have one two three
four five six four these kids to you
next Guthrie offers a strange response
saying the kids are his friends and that
one girl is over 18.
uh this is my friend that's your friend
yeah how's your friend
18.
that goes not 18.
that was not 18. yeah no she's not
cheers that girl's not 18. trust me
she'll look 18.
ma'am how old are you
I'm not sure your name I actually held
you were
when the girl refuses to give her age
the sergeant asks Guthrie to get out of
the vehicle
Jeremy turn the car up and come back and
talk to me all right
let me see the keys
thank you
come on
it's then that Guthrie is caught with
his zipper down
Roger why why is your zipper your
buttons down on your crotch
well I probably just forgot okay and
I'll find my zipper yeah please buy your
zipper yeah I mean I had a I had to take
it like a piss and um
good at first Guthrie claims he hasn't
been drinking but later admits he had a
few drinks several hours ago when's your
last drink
like
probably
um
it's been a it's been a little while
like an hour
I would say it's more than a
minute maybe two yeah roughly okay like
two hours that's fair because you know
what two hours it's totally is totally
different than no I haven't been
drinking
you know what I mean yeah but I mean
we're not gonna argue about it I mean I
know what I smell I know what I hear I
know what I see
okay
simple as that
I mean yeah I mean I'm not gonna lie to
you well you already did
you said I haven't been drinking
and then I kind of played you said was
an hour ago like no longer two hours
yeah
it's been a few hours okay I mean gotcha
well I mean we're not gonna argue about
that I mean I know what I smell okay do
you think you're safe to drive
do you think you're safe to drive yeah
you do
absolutely once again you and I would
disagree on that too
I don't think you're safe to drive just
basically just based on on how you're
driving when the sergeant again asks
about the kids inside Guthrie's vehicle
he has another bizarre response all
those people in the card who are they
they're just my friends I mean do you
normally hang out with
people who who are young
not
uh how old are you
I'm 41. 41k hang tight right there okay
the sergeant then approaches the kids
asking their ages how old are you
and don't lie to me okay like I'm gonna
play this the game where you lie I know
that I know that you're not 18. okay
so if you want to have attitude you in
the front Okay we go about another way
simple as that
so if so if I sense any attitude or you
give me lip we'll do it another way
okay Hallelujah
14. thank you so simple question 13.
really 14 okay
okay
13. okay
14. okay who's this guy to anybody
okay so
that there's your homie okay so you guys
all need to call your parents you see
okay
okay and happy Parents meet up meet us
here the first responder explains he may
have saved all the children's lives that
night by pulling Guthrie over just so
you guys know
okay I probably saved Six Lives tonight
at least six lives okay I thought you
guys are gonna crash around that bench
he's going way too fast and he's
definitely
not safe to drive oh yeah we told me he
then speaks with several parents calling
for them to come pick up their children
this is this is Sergeant Lafayette with
State Police
and you're
you're your son along with the guessing
three uh five of the other buddies they
were in a they're in a vehicle with
somebody who some man it's a grown adult
who has who has no business driving and
so he's out now doing physical body
tests and
these kids need to be picked up
meanwhile another first responder
conducts field sobriety tests with
Guthrie so just to make sure that you're
okay to drive okay uh would you mind uh
doing a couple of field sobriety tests
just to make sure
yeah yeah you would mind or would or you
would you would want to do
was it
uh do you mind or or do
you want to do them do you want to do
them yes or no
I don't really want to you don't want to
do them no no
okay I'm just gonna let you know if you
don't do the test I'm gonna have to
place you under arrest
you want to do the test all right
you don't know what's after each I don't
like that one
are you going to stop the testing well
I'll still
test okay so are you gonna continue or
you can stop right there I just don't
understand this
you're going backwards you're going
eight all right
I just don't understand
I told you to go forward remember
information from H to S it's pretty
simple oh
h
I
j k
l
all right I just didn't understand what
you wanted yeah all right
around me I'm going to turn around
all right so you're gonna be placed
under arrest for DWI okay
don't don't forget his phone I'll put it
I'll put it up in the front seat easier
Guthrie is then placed under arrest
anything you say Canon will be used
against you in court of law you have the
right to talk to a lawyer and have him
or her present with you while you're
being questioned if you cannot afford to
hire a lawyer one will be appointed to
represent you before any questioning if
you wish you can decide at any time to
exercise these rights and not answer any
questions or make any statements do you
understand each of these rights as I've
explained to you
sorry could you say that again
yes or no
okay yes or no no yeah okay Guthrie was
charged with driving while under the
influence and six counts of child abuse
he was later also charged with multiple
counts of rape prosecutors allege he
began a relationship with one of the 13
year olds in his vehicle back when she
was 12. they also alleged she became
pregnant but suffered a miscarriage
Guthrie is due back in court in October
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie